you know what one thing from Connor that
you know when he was a first time he
fought Diaz and I don't know if you
remember the first fight that of course
I'm sure you've seen the fight but the
first time he fought Diaz he hit him and
he went to him yeah he hit him and he
went to him he hit him and he went to
him right he's trying to say I'm gonna
beat you at your game as well you know
kind of like that's what I'm going to be
doing now you know people thought
Francis and gano's last fight he was
just gonna do stand up he didn't he beat
him and ground as well which was kind of
like damn yeah nobody expected him to do
this so Connor lost the first fight even
though he was supposed to win the first
fight right he lost the first fight
second fight I don't know if you
remember first time he knocks he had
some Nate drops yeah and uh oh you know
he's not going to him yeah and then you
hear Jonah was like oh he's not going to
him he's asking him stand up then he
stands up again happens he did it three
times to him yep he did never went to
him which you know props to him for
having that uh
control during that moment to know hey
this is not what I should do because
that guy's better than me in this area
yeah let's just say you're fighting
Dustin and all of a sudden you're like
okay this guy packs a punch you know and
you pack a punch both of you guys pack a
punch but you know do you think the the
strategy and you don't have to tell me
anything I'm you know again on what I'm
saying with this part but I'm only
asking this because for me if you know
khabib would show he can hang
you know and then but all of a sudden
khabib would go and say nah man this is
not my fight I'm gonna beat you at my
fight how hard is it to set aside your
own Spirit of competition and fire to
say dude I know if I wrestle you I'm
gonna beat you but I want to beat you at
your fight to say I kind of need this
victory for me to be on a two win streak
three one streak four one streak then
I'm gonna get through Charles back again
let's just say Charles doesn't have the
title by that time it's going to be
another person I'm still going to get
that championship fight then I'm going
to get the big payday let's just say
Conor comes back because Dana wants to
the two of you guys to fight
do you do you are you going to take a
khabibra out are you going to take the
entertainment route no I'm definitely
taking the win route okay I'm taking
that I will I will obviously every every
fight starts on the feet yeah um so
we'll start on the feed obviously you
know if if the you know a lot of times
too you there's that fine line between
fight or flight and being able to
actually make decisions on the Fly uh or
maybe you're just flowing and you make a
decision and all of a sudden you take a
guy down you didn't even try to shoot it
just happened your body shot you grabbed
a leg you picked them up and put them
down you know there's it's such a it's
such an interesting
mindset when you're actually in there
because people say it all the time why
did you do this or why did you do that
and I'm like I really didn't have
control over it you know maybe maybe I
should have done a little bit more work
uh at visualization maybe I should have
done a little bit more work in my
training of of of use doing more dry
runs and more situationals and more
opportunities to make sure I make the
right decisions but a lot of times
you're not really a hundred percent in
control as much as the the media and the
fans and the onlookers think that you
are but truthfully yes there will be a
game plan and that game plan will be
mixing it out and about you know we're
fans you know no it's good no I I
appreciate it because that's a good it's
a good it's a very good question because
yeah you have to I've done a very good
job I think thus far of creating a brand
of Michael Chandler's in a very exciting
fighter but no you you're the most well
thank you and listen Cosmic look I'm not
going to tell you he's not exciting I'm
not going to tell you Alexander you know
uh Israel no no no no no what's his name
is
[ __ ] he's freaking but to me you're the
most exciting fighter period that's my
opinion you know you're the most
exciting fighter when you when you fight
I can't sit down I have to stand up when
I'm watching your fight I can't sit down
watch your fight I gotta come watch a
fight with you something
what is it I love the backflips
what is it during the fight that excites
you so much for example like you know
you uh I don't want to say this because
it's your friend oh God Tyron you know
he he was coming up in like four times
and then all of a sudden he started like
you know playing it too safe and even
Dana got at one point it was like what
is this guy doing though we gotta sell
tickets here you know this is not just
about the points and scoring the points
we need a little bit of both like get in
there so he got a little too much to be
too careful to get the Victory and
that's not good you saw the other day
Israel had a fight people were born I
don't know if you remember the Israel
fight where they were born it's like
what was that all about listen I'm
scoring the points and then the two
girls that fought the worst fighter ever
that was on that was on my card I think
do you do I think so which actually
works out really well I've been very
fortunate to have some somewhat boring
fights
by the way did you watch that fight did
you actually watch that fight or you
didn't get it because it's your card so
I don't know if you watched it no
usually that was right after me and I I
went and did probably 20 30 minutes it
was it was the most important let me
tell you in five
each other one time that's very weird
right so you have to sell tickets so as
a Dana White like you you want guys like
you like Conor like you know you're not
gonna do what Connor does so you know
the difference between you and Connor is
Connor's gonna do laps around you and
talking smack right and not just you
anybody including Mayweather like oh my
God Conor is a top five smack talker in
the world today I don't know who I put
ahead of him maybe you got him you got
Trump you got Jake you got some of these
guys that are fantastic Elon Musk is a
troll some of these guys Connor's on
another level no no he's on a whole
different level when he does it so
you're like you just yeah I watched the
the press conference with Mayweather
more than I watch the fight yeah and I
watched the press conference more times
than I watched the fight one time I
watched the conference that was fun so
so but but the but the part where I'm
going with this is
you know there's the balance of the
eyeballs and then there is the journey
to go get the championship to get that
part uh man it's it's it's got to be and
then you know when you're talking when
you're fighting getting hit you don't
know if you're getting hit and all that
other stuff and one of the fights that
you had you know when you're fighting
like because you'll go all out with
everybody you're not gonna stop but
you're saying what is the most exciting
part from the first second to the last
second he's moving yeah there is no like
uh you know there is no oh gas no breaks
no he's fighting from beginning to the
end he's fighting and it's it's hard
it's hard to see those kinds of fights
yes he brings it so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]